previously on Mars I will miss my sister
she's my heart and soul something ladies
to work it has to be personal we had
traveled further than anyone ever had to
get to Mars before round and entered
Mars atmosphere it was like she was
trying to push herself
rockets are about to fire
and once we landed she pushed even
harder wood has been status how far did
we overshoot seventy five point three
kilometers ma let's finish this it's our
guys up there the workout module but if
they can make it that living it they
have a chance it was five or six just
locked pension system compromised we
have to walk it's minus 35 degrees it
will be minus 70 why not face death far
of course we struggle to make our way to
a temporary house we need to cut the
ships fighting just to stay on line stay
with me come on remember to me still our
mission remained to find a safe haven
for the first human settlement on Mars
forgetting their had killed the best
among us I was in command now and I knew
if we couldn't find a permanent home in
this place
the Mars mission would die
[Music]
[Music]